the year 2000
the United States ranked sixth in our
human Freedom index it now ranks 23. so
this this is it particularly I want to
show that chart uh yeah here's the
ranking we've got uh Switzerland New
Zealand Estonia Denmark Ireland rounding
out the top five and then you go down
U.S at 23 below Belgium and Austria and
the United Kingdom if you look at the
graph of freedom in the United States it
doesn't look like the global the global
graph it didn't it wasn't increasing uh
okay a thousand that's that's one of the
worrisome things that that we found
because you asked why is there this
increase it's because all sorts of other
countries were still increasing their
freedom around the world not the United
States the United States is a very
worrisome Trend starting from around the
year 2000 of a long-term steady decline
in Freedom that then with the with the
global financial crisis it it it it
accelerated and
um and
we especially see that beginning in the
year 2000 in the economic freedom side
of things because of exactly the kinds
of things that that you mentioned and
out of the five different indicators in
in economic freedom about broad
categories that we look at size of
government the legal system and property
rights sound money freedom to trade and
regulation all of them saw notable drops
during during this uh period of time
except that the rule of law indicator
saw the biggest drop it was a it was a
very big drop and that accelerated with
the financial crisis but that was
already going on and it really started
uh with the beginning of the Bush
Administration and we think that that's
due to a lot of things
um the wars the war on terror uh the War
on Drugs
um the weakening of private property
rights in the United States with the
kilo decision over a decade ago
um I think that the financial crisis
made things worse because there was a
rise of crony capitalism or at least
what people perceived as crony
capitalism where Industries and and in
fact particular companies close to power
uh got privileges and massive amounts of
bailouts even though uh that that wasn't
necessarily Justified and all of these
things combined to to weaken the rule of
law because it's it's arbitrary and at
the very least that's perceived as such
and when you have the rules of the game
not uh not viewed as as Fair that's a
real threat to other freedoms but we did
see other other areas of Freedom like uh
government spending and uh monetary
policy and freedom to trade start to
start to go down as well and this
uh accelerated during the financial
crisis it started to recover some and
with the pandemic it it came down never
did the United States recover its level
of Freedom that it had in the year 2000
um when it when it used to rank at the
top here's a breakdown of the analysis
of the United States as you mentioned
rule of law as a is it a meager 6.3
um movement 6.4 affected negatively by
the pandemic of course size of
government 6.8
what's our what are some of the
immediate steps that should be taken to
you know reverse these Trends and you
know get the us at least back into the
top 10 of you know Freedom ranked
countries
well I mean there's a lot that can be
done in terms of economic freedom we're
way below in in economic freedom than
what we were in the year 2000 and that
that in terms of
free trade in terms of regulations in
terms of
sound money and in every indicator we're
we're below and so all of those policies
can can be improved the size of
government is is much larger today after
Obama after Trump uh during the day
after Bush right I mean it's just much
larger than when Bush came in if I may
in 2019 because this you know when we
talk about the the covid exception
2019 spending this was under Donald
Trump uh and it was a record at the time
that the federal budget spent four or
federal government spent 4.4 trillion
dollars in 2020 it's been 6.6 trillion
dollars in 2021 6.8 last year and went
down to 6.3 slightly this year it's
estimated to be 6.4 and this is you know
this seems to vindicate the uh the Higgs
hypothesis of a kind of ratchet effect
so you know it's gone down from 6.8
percent but it's much closer to that
than it is to 4.4 which was already
insane compared to you know Bill Clinton
uh 20 years earlier
that's right so I think that that that
that that uh hypothesis is still valid
for the United States after these these
crises and um you know there were
several crises during the Bush
Administration which which did help to
increase government spending at a time
at least in his the first part of his
administration where the Republicans
controlled both you know uh the the
Congress and the executive and um that's
oftentimes not a good thing yeah and
it's interesting now not to get too into
Weeds about uh you know government uh
spending in America but you know when
when Obama came in uh in 2009 he of
course he won what was con you know what
was rightly considered a mandate at the
time and the Democrats took they uh they
had control of the house but they took
control of the Senate he he did have a
blank check for two years and spending
went up and they got everything they
wanted basically and that elected a
republican Congress and then things
started leveling off I mean I'm not a
huge fan of divided government because
it's you know at various points it seems
as if you know spending just keeps going
up anyway but
um you know at least in uh the late Bush
years and the the second half of Obama
things leveled off a bit because it it
seems uh you know a divided government
put the put the brakes on certain split
so behind all of these Trends is how
people view government and how people
feel about society and and politics and
and so on and uh one of the things that
we
that we see is when you look at the
global picture and you see the high
point at 2007 and then it starts going
down the financial crisis that's a
period of time where you you really see
the rise of different forms of populism
during during this uh subsequent period
of time all over the world authoritarian
populism of the left of the right uh in
a lot of countries is taking over and in
a lot of political systems having a
bigger say in politics including in
Liberal democracies as occur has
occurred in the United States I would
argue in both parties
um
the the the what happened I think in the
United States beginning during the Bush
Administration
um which as I say had its own crises and
expanded uh the role of government so it
was reducing freedom is if you look at
the at the
um surveys by Pew and by Gallup you see
that over the past 15 to 20 years in the
United States trust in almost every
institution in society starts coming
down and it's it's hitting record lows
on so many different institutions we're
talking about
um the the uh the media uh Congress the
exactly the things like the Catholic
church and philanthropies are actually
also saying
um uh businesses you know big businesses
and and other kinds of businesses and so
when when there is a loss of trust in
the main institutions in society that
mediate uh interaction in society uh
you're in Latin American territory and
that's when Trump came in and that's I I
very much view Trump as a Latin American
populist uh but I think that he didn't
come out of nowhere something was going
on in the United States that led people
to think hey you know the rules of the
game aren't aren't Fair anymore we don't
trust this institution or that
institution yeah and both he and Hillary
Clinton this was uh striking to me in
the rhetoric in 2016 they both
explicitly said the system is broken you
know they offered different reasons for
why it was broken what was broken in it
and how they would fix it but it was uh
fairly chilling and you know and I think
on some profound level accurate I mean
certainly there's a reason why they were
the candidates and they were both saying
the system is broken you can't trust the
system the system doesn't care about you
it's not watching out for you but of
course they took no responsibility for
that system no no of course been a part
of it I think that that's been a really
big problem for for especially for the
Democrats who um uh have a lot of uh
correct uh gripes about uh Republicans
or or Trump uh they themselves have
become at least a big part of the the
democrators have become uh more
radicalized but they don't take into
account the role that their ideas had
and continue to have in creating the
political polarization I very much see
the uh the political polarization in the
United States and the and what's going
on now as a legacy of Obama and even of
bush so
um unfortunately I don't think that
there has been a great
um explanation uh so far analysis of why
that has happened and
um we can come up with a lot of
plausible stories that I think can
um be compelling but the fact of the
matter is that this polarization and
this rise of populisms either on the
left or right or both has been going on
All Around the World in countries that
are completely different from one
another in terms of wealth in terms of
the political system in terms of culture
I mean we're talking about this
happening in Mexico and Chile two very
different uh societies and in India and
in Hungary and you know the the
hardening of nationalisms and so on in
Russia and in China turkey and in parts
of Western Europe where major political
parties have become uh radicalized or
include very radical uh parties is part
of their coalitions hey thanks for
watching that excerpt from our
conversation with Ian Vasquez of the
Cato Institute about the state of human
Freedom worldwide post covid you can
watch our full conversation right here
or another clip from that conversation
right here and subscribe to reason TV to
get these conversations live every
Thursday at 1 pm Eastern